Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this piece of work, we are interested in
creating a 3D virtual tour for an apartment.
However, for this apartment, no 3D information
is available - instead, the input for the
algorithm is something that we can obtain
easily, in this case, a 2D floorplan and a
set of images that we shot in the apartment.
From this information, we would create a 3D
floorplan that is not only faithful to the
real one in terms of geometry, but the photos
with the correct viewpoints are also to be
assigned to the correct walls.
In order to accomplish this, one has to overcome
a series of challenging problems.
For instance, we have to estimate the layout
of each room and find the location of the
camera in each of these images.
Also, to obtain high-quality solutions, the
goal is to extract as much information from
the inputs as possible.
The authors recognized that the floorplans
provide way more information than we take
for granted.
For instance, beyond showing the geometric
relation of the rooms, it can also be used
to find out the aspect ratios of the floor
for each room.
The window-to-wall ratios can also be approximated
and matched between the photos and the floorplan.
This additional information is super useful
when trying to find out which room is to be
assigned to which part of the 3D floorplan.
Beyond just looking at the photos, we also
have access to a large swath of learning algorithms
that can reliably classify whether we're looking
at a bathroom or a living room.
There are even more constraints to adhere
to in order to aggressively reduce the number
of physical configurations, make sure to have
a look at the paper for details, there are
lots of cool tricks described there.
As always, there is a link to it in the video
description.
For instance, since the space of possible
solutions is still too vast, a branch and
bound type algorithm is proposed to further
decimate the number of potential solutions
to evaluate.
And as you can see here, the comparisons against
ground truth floorplans reveal that these
solutions are indeed quite faithful to reality.
The authors also kindly provided a dataset
with more than 200 full apartments with well
over a thousand photos and annotations for
future use in followup research works.
Creating such a dataset and publishing it
is incredibly laborious, and could easily
be a paper on its own, and here, we also get
an excellent solution for this problem as
well.
In a separate work, the authors also published
a different version of this problem formulation
that reconstructs the exteriors of buildings
in a similar manner.
There is so much to explore, the links are
available in the video description, make sure
to have a look!
In case you're wondering, it's still considered
a crime not doing that.
I hope you have enjoyed this episode, and
I find it so delightful to see this unbelievably
rapid growth on the channel.
Earlier I thought that even 2 would be amazing,
but now, we have exactly 8 times as many subscribers
as one year ago.
Words fail me to describe the joy of showing
these amazing works to such a rapidly growing
audience.
This is why I always say at the end of every
episode...
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!